Let's recap some of the important topics we've
covered in this particular lecture. We've
talked about the fundamental image formation
process and the simplest case is what we call
the "Pinhole Camera." Light comes from a light
source, in this case the sun, reflects off
points on the three dimensional object, those
light rays pass through the pin hole and cause
a very faint inverted image to be formed on
the image plane.
The geometry of this situation can be very
simply explained. It can be described using
similar triangles and that leads us to the
very simple relationship here between three
dimensional world co-ordinates, capital X,
capital Y, capital Z and the two dimensional
image plane co-ordinates little x and little y.
So this is a mapping or a projection from
three dimensions down to two dimensions and
this is called "Perspective Projection."
One of the disadvantages of the pinhole imaging
model is that a lot of the light rays are
lost; they simply hit the opaque plane that
holds the pinhole. If we introduce a lens
instead we're able to gather many more of
the rays that leave each particular point
on the object and that allows a brighter image
to be formed.
A consequence of the perspective projection,
the mapping from three dimensions down into
two, is that some of the geometry is not preserved.
Here we see that parallel lines in the world
are no longer parallel lines in the image.
We see that a large circle in the world is
not a circle in the image. And perspective
projection guarantees only to do this, it
will map a line to a line, but it doesn't
necessarily retain parallelism, angles are
not necessarily preserved and conic sections
are mapped to conic sections; so that means
that a circle could appear as an ellipse and
an ellipse could appear as a circle.
A really important consequence of the perspective
projection is that there is no unique inverse.
We've lost a dimension, so for a particular
image there are an infinite number of possible
objects that could have caused that image.
It could be a small object close to me or
it could be a large object further away. There
is no way, just from the image geometry that
we can tell this.
So in practice we use a number of tricks that
come from our experience from growing up in
a three dimensional world, in order to disambiguate
this. Though we can trick this. If we create
a two dimensional image; shown here as a piece
of street art, which causes on the retina
of our eye, exactly the same image as we would
get from looking at a three dimensional world,
then all of the three dimensional interpretation
part of our brain kicks in and causes us to
feel, to interpret the image as being three
dimensional even though the rational part
of our brain knows that this is a piece of
flat street art. The impression is still very,
very vivid.
Another way we can look at the consequence
of there being no unique inverse is in an
illusion like this and it's because Chris
is a full size person but because he's standing
further away he appears to be smaller and
although initially we're surprised when we
look at that, again the rational part of our
brain that understands the three dimensional
world kicks in and says "Okay, actually we
will assume that he is a full size person,
he therefore must be further away."